Цифру в тисячу померлих від коронавірусу на день ми однозначно перейдемо.
Хочеться накласти на себе руки, вистрибнути з вікна, коли ти розумієш, що ти цим людям міг би реально допомогти.
Я вважаю, що треба скликати РНБО і обговорювати "дельту".
Якщо немає місць у реанімації, то це є колапс! То це не те, що показник для локдауну, а це те, що ви вже спізнилися з його впровадженням!
Щоб заразитися уханським первинним вірусом треба було вдихнути 1000 вірусів, то для "дельти" достатньо сто.
Ваші поради для профілактики коронавірусу?
Всього два слова - вакцинація і вентиляція. Вакцинація людей і вентиляція приміщень.
Жодна вакцина в цілому світі не протестована настільки інтенсивно, як вакцина проти коронавіруса!
Вчитель, який проти вакцинації, лікар, який проти, політик, який проти - для мене це взагалі незрозуміло, як таке може бути?
Фігушки, народе! Не дають нам ніяких грошей за вакцинацію!
Чим менше пенсіонерів, тим більше доріг.
Буде наркоманія, токсикоманія, все це буде!
Діти збираються в кімнатах, сидять з чіпсами, дивляться усіляку фігню в інтернеті. І це окрема проблема, через яку має зібратися РНБО.
Я - класична Кассандра. Все, що я говорю, я вже розповідав років 15 останніх!
Пане Комаровський, нещодавно Ви заявили, що через коронавірус для багатьох ця осінь може стати останньою.
Наскільки критична нині ситуація в Україні?
Якщо не справляється система охорони здоров’я, це означає, що критично.
Якщо лікарі роблять вибір, що цього брати в стаціонар, а цього не брати, тому що там немає місць,
або цього класти в реанімацію, а цього не класти, то це ситуація однозначно критична.
Коли чекати піку цієї хвилі коронавірусу?
Думаю, зараз буде реальне загострення, тому що стане холодніше.
Чим менше люди на свіжому повітрі, тим більше вони товчуться в приміщеннях, тим буде гірше.
Тому зараз скоріше за все буде різкий спалах, який буде тривати близько 2-3 тижнів. Потім буде пік, потім має стати легше.
Ви сказали, що оскільки лікарі вже обирають кого куди направляти, чим це відрізняється від ситуації минулого року?
Ну, якщо раніше слід було обирати одного з двох, то тепер одного з п’ятьох.
У нас вже критерій - вік, коли негласно говорять, мовляв, хлопці, давайте вже людей старше 60-ти реанімацію не брати,
тому що в реанімації повно тих, кому 30-40 років.
Тобто вже навіть не рівень сатурації розглядають, а вік.
У кого більше шансів вижити, того і будемо рятувати.
Як Ви до цього ставитися?
Жахливо, звичайно. Це взагалі жахливо, коли лікар має вирішувати, кого рятувати.
Це тактика надання допомоги на полі бою. Це воєнна доктрина. Оберіть того, кого можна врятувати!
Так, про це говорив Пирогов. Багато років тому. Так що ми повернулися в 21-му сторіччі в 19-те.
До яких цифр слід готуватися?
Цифру в тисячу померлих від коронавірусу на день ми однозначно перейдемо.
І якщо врахувати те, що ми не маємо об’єктивної інформації, тому що велика кількість людей помирають вдома,
не встигнувши звернутися до лікарів, не встигнувши обстежитися…
А якщо йому не встигли зробити ПЦР, то він "офіційно" помре просто від запалення легень.
А скільки людей на тлі коронавірусної інфекції з тромбозами помруть від інфарктів, інсультів.
Фактично, їх вб’є "ковід", але офіційно це будуть смерті, не пов’язані з "ковідом".
Як Ви думаєте, скільки людей наразі лікується вдома?
Я думаю, що на одного в стаціонарі - 3-4 вдома.
Наразі дефіцит не лише кисню та ліжко-місць. Дуже гострий дефіцит - дефіцит медперсоналу: лікарів, медсестр.
Їх  катастрофічно не вистачає. На одне відділення в 60 ліжок може залишитися на ніч лише одна медсестра.
Уявіть собі! Це взагалі-то не дуже медицина, м’яко кажучи.
Це воєнна медицина, фактично, воєнна охорона здоров’я. Просто треба про це говорити.
З цього слід зробити далекоглядні політичні висновки.
А взагалі Ви знаєте, що треба враховувати? Що люди при дефіциті кисню втрачають орієнтацію в просторі.
Часто стають агресивними , зривають із себе кисневі маски, обладнання, ламають його, проявляють агресію.
Це одна з ознак кисневої недостатності. А як Ви думаєте, в стаціонарах є люди, які можуть допомогти медсестрам? А де волонтерський рух?
Там він має бути! А де наша взаємодопомога та взаємовиручка? Де? Де? А де церква зрештою?
Я до того веду, що ми стрімко втрачаємо, і не тільки ми - весь світ втрачає ось ці основи моралі:
допомагати слабким, рятувати, турбуватися про людей похилого віку.
Це ж ми повинні були бігати та кричати, що серед людей похилого віку смертність 10-15%-20%!
Давайте, бабусі, ми вас захистимо! Вас насамперед! Ви - наше все! А нам на них, як зазвичай, було наплювати.
Як ця ситуація  впливає на лікарів?
Хочеться накласти на себе руки, вистрибнути з вікна, коли ти розумієш, що ти цим людям міг би реально допомогти.
Якби це все було в іншій країні. Якби тобі наразі надали обладнання, помічників. Якби на тебе раніше звернули увагу.
Якби ти розумів, що в тебе не просто має бути кисень.
А якщо в тебе 100 пацієнтів, то запасів кисню в тебе має бути на тисячу, щоб ти не думав про те, що він зараз скінчиться.
Про те, що я зараз трохи прикручу, прикручу, щоб ти отримав 5 літрів на хвилину.
Тому що краще, щоб 10 отримували 5 літрів на хвилину, хоча їм потрібно не 5, а 10 літрів на хвилину. Але мені тоді вистачить на більшу кількість хворих.
Тому що кисню немає, то прикручують?
Якщо у вас реально залишилося кисню... Ось у вас 10 хворих. І у вас залишилося 1000 літрів кисню.
І вони кожен будуть отримувати по 10 літрів на годину , то на скільки їм вистачать?
І це потім родичі розлючені будуть бігати навколо цих лікарів і кричати, що це ви вбили.
Не той, хто вчасно не допоміг, не той, хто вчасно не придбав обладнання, не той, хто не організував людям похилого віку вакцинацію!
А ці лікарі, які поряд. Я це знаю чудово. Я через це три тисячі разів у житті проходив.
Киснева криза була минулого року. І минулого року було багато обіцянок, що ця проблема буде вирішена. І буде виділено багато коштів…
Це не просто біда, а це біда, про яку ми заздалегідь знали, що вона прийде.
Більше того, ми заздалегідь знали, який контингент людей найбільш уразливий.
І те, що ми не захистили цих людей і не створили умови в стаціонарах, не потурбувалися про людей, які на передньому фронті -
це помилка людей, які приймають політичні рішення.
Які причини нового витка епідемії і таких високих цифр?
Насамперед, це "дельта" як надзвичайно заразний штам.
Він чітко підтвердив всі епідеміологічні характеристики коронавірусу з акцентом на те, що вірус розповсюджується головним чином через повітря.
Тому основою профілактики є повітряний обмін в приміщеннях насамперед.
Як тільки люди починають активно спілкуватися в приміщенні, де немає припливно-витяжної вентиляції контрольованої,
то захворюваність різко зростає, бо зростає концентрація вірусу у повітрі, яким дихають.
А для вірусу, щоб зараження саме "дельтою" відбулося, потрібна менша доза.
Умовно кажучи, щоб заразитися уханським первинним вірусом треба було вдихнути 1000 вірусів, то для "дельти" достатньо сто.
І це один з факторів. І, звичайно, ми ж самі… Всі ці  соціальні дистанції, маски… Це так, щоб відчепилися.
У людина маска одна і та же, лежить в кишені 2-3 місяці, він її надягає, ніс стирчить над маскою.
Це все чиста показуха. Все, що від нас вимагає держава, викликає в нас протидію. Нам не хочеться цього робити.
Якщо держава нас про щось попросила - і перший імпульс, що ми робимо, - ми цього не робимо.
Тому що ми упродовж багатьох років, упродовж сторічь знаходимося у стані постійної конфронтації з державою.
Якщо держава щось просить, то це як справа честі - не робити так, як просить держава.
Чим ця хвиля відрізняється від попередніх?
Відрізняється насамперед суспільним маразмом.
Тому що, вибачте, коли на вас насувається хвиля, а у вас є човен, але ви не бажаєте туди залазити…
Ось ви не хочете і кажете, що цей човен віднесе мене кудись, загрожує безпліддям тощо, розумієте?
Не полізу я в човен, я краще потону!
Ви про вакцинацію?
Про вакцинацію в тому числі. Коли в тебе є зрозумілий інструмент, як захиститися. А ти шукаєш причини цього не робити.
При чому в тебе немає ніяких шансів оминути це, розумієте? Жодних!
А я все одно не хочу захищатися. Я дуже боюся. Я буду безплідним, страшенно безплідним… Я помру, але не буду… Ех…
Це настільки виходить за рамки добра, логіки, здорового глузду! Мені хочеться ридати, плакати.
Але я вже адаптований до цього. Тому що з відсутністю логіки, здорового глузду я зіштовхуюся все своє медичне життя.
Я сорок років людей чомусь навчаю і бачу… Інше питання, що я можу обирати собі пацієнтів, тому контактую з адекватними в міру сил. А навчаю усіх.
Станом на нині в Україні повністю щеплено 17 відсотків населення. Це дає підстави говорити про провал кампанії з вакцинації?
Я не бачив особливої кампанії, якщо чесно. Насамперед головне, що держава мала зробити, вона зробила - це забезпечила вакциною.
Вакцина в країні є. Далі, дійсно, кампанія чи ні, але треба було щось зробити, щоб люди почали вакцинуватися! Які для цього є інструменти?
Є роз’яснення, заохочування, мотивація, приклад. Все. Крапка.
Я точно знаю, що в країні є авторитетні люди, яких важко звинуватити у приналежності до держави.
Я кажу про блогерів, артистів, митців, модних дизайнерів, кулінарів. Купа людей, які користуються любов’ю людей.
Нам треба було зробити так, щоб ці люди були за вакцинацію.
Щоб це стало модним, класним, трендом адекватності, інтелігентності суспільства.
Якась кампанія була нібито минулого року...
Та кого Ви можете мені назвати з тих, хто вакцинувався, закликав людей до цього?
Знаєте в чому біда? В тому, що нині гроші вирішують все.
І будь-який артист, який скаже, що, мовляв, вакцинуйтеся, знає, що від нього відпишуться половна прихильників. Тому він промовчить.
Без доброти та допомоги слабким ми вже не країна будемо, а звіряче суспільство, де чим менше пенсіонерів, тим більше доріг.
Скільки  підписників відписалися від Вас? Через те, що ви відвертий прихильник вакцинації?
На щастя, я розповідаю людям не лише про вакцинацію.
Я розповідаю про педагогіку, психологію, дитячу безпеку, невідкладну допомогу, і про нежить,  какашки, ліки - про все, що завгодно.
Тому, на мене підписуються не лише через вакцинацію.
Але вакцинація - кожен пост про це, за нашими даними, від двох до шести тисяч людей відписувалися.
А останній мій, так би мовити, лайливий крик, що якщо у вас є розум, то вакцинуйтеся, дав нам плюс 50 000 підписників.
Виходить, що про вакцинацію можна говорити лише так.
Працює тільки щось конкретне,  щось на кшталт істерики.
Хоча чесно скажу, що моя дружина, коли побачила цей пост, сказала, що якби тебе не знала,
то сказала би, що тобі дали за це гроші, бо неможливо розповідати на таких емоціях людям, які після цього тебе облають мільйонами коментарів.
Чи вакцинувалися Ви самі від коронавірусу?
Звичайно.
І якою вакциною?
Перша, яка з’явилася в країні. "Ковішилдом" від "Астразенека". Через три місяці друга доза.
Через три місяці, тому що я вважав і є такі дані, що "Астразенека" має максимальну ефективність, якщо повторна вакцинація через три місяці.
Хоча зараз усіх закликають через місяць вакцинуватися, щоб не тягнути, щоб був більш високий рівень імунітету.
Чи були у Вас якісь побічні ефекти?
Ні, ніяких. У місці ін’єкції трохи боліло.
Ви самі перехворіли на коронавірус?
Так, у легкій формі. І симптоматика легка, але наслідки…
Нюх та смак відновилися після восьми місяців найлегшої форми хвороби.
Як ви ставитеся до аргументів тих, хто не хоче щепитися чи носити маски в громадських місцях?
Що ця вакцина незрозуміло що, маски не врятують…
Коли люди намагаються знайти, скажімо так, відмазку, чому я не хочу вакцинуватися...
Насправді часто-густо це нагадує мені певну исдкусію на релігійні теми, в мене повна аналогія.
Ось, я вірю в те, що вакцини допомагають. Або я не вірю в те, що вакцини допомагають.
Якщо ми до цього ставимося раціонально, то дивіться.
На Землі на сьогодні введено майже, замисліться, 8 млрд доз протикоронавірусної інфекції. 8 млрд доз!
Більше того, ми вводимо протикоронавірусні вакцини в той час, коли кожна введена вакцина залишає електронний слід.
Тобто ми не просто вводимо десь у лісі. Кожна доза, що ввели, ми знаємо вік людини, параметри, де, коли.
Та оскільки це все в електронному виді, то це величезний масив інформації, щоб аналізувати ефективність, безпеку, побічні ефекти.
Жодна вакцина в цілому світі не протестована настільки інтенсивно, як коронавірусна інфекція!
Бог з ними, з цими тестами! Ми маємо конкретику.
Ось, відділення реанімації в Києві, Харкові, Одесі, Львові, Мінську, де завгодно - там 99% людей не вакциновані.
А ті, які нібито вакциновані, в 50 % випадків з фальсифікованими документами.
Багато хто побоюється довгострокових наслідків?
А смерті ви не боїтеся? Ну, добре, мовляв, я боюся якихось наслідків - заради Бога, бійтеся. Але раціональність має бути!
Я не хочу пристібатися ременем безпеки, я боюся довгострокових наслідків! Ось, тут мені натре і буде свербіж  шкіри...
Ще одна з причин, чому люди сумніваються, це недовіра до  медичної системи. Вакцина може бути простроченою. Або не дотримані правильні умови.
Без сумніву, люди можуть так вважати. Давайте сформулюємо: ми боїмося не вакцинації, ми за вакцинацію. Але тільки ми за що?
За чесну, грамотну вакцинацію, під контролем суспільства.
Тільки суспільство навіть не намагається. От, якщо ми хочемо вакцинуватися, але хочемо вакцинуватися  нормальними вакцинами,
то давайте тоді створимо якусь громадську організацію, і наші представники будуть присутні на всіх етапах, де вакцини транспортуються,
будемо відстежувати логістику, будемо дивитися, в яких умовах вони зберігаються. Але це логічно, якщо ми за вакцинацію.
Ще нині в соцмережах часто розкручують думку, що за кожну вколоту вакцину від ковіду лікарі отримують гроші,
мовляв, хтось заробляє на тому що нас колять якимось неперевіреним препаратом?
Найсмішніше те, що я це питання намагаюся підняти вже 40 років.
Ще коли я тільки почав працювати педіатром, то мені вже тоді розповіли, що, виходить, у лікарів є план вакцинації і за його виконання вони отримують гроші.
Фігушки, народе! Не дають нам ніяких грошей за це! Ні! Нічого подібного немає. І найголовніше, ніколи не було.
Як Ви думаєте, якби Україна мала свою власну вакцину, ситуація з рівнем вакцинації була б кращою?
Україна не могла мати свою власну вакцину, тому що в нас для цього немає жодних ресурсів. Нуль! Ми все зробили, щоб це було знищено під корінь.
Вакцинація - це передовий бік медичної науки. Якщо вона в нас і з’явиться, то ми будемо просто розливати по ампулках те, що нам привезуть.
Нам привезуть якась діжку з вакциною від Пфайзер, то ми тут її розіллємо, і це буде буцімто наша вакцина.
Те, що називається локалізоване виробництво. Я не впевнений, що якби була наша вакцина….
Можна подумати, якби в нас була наша машина, автомобіль, то ми би його любили більше.
Загальне падіння культури й інтелекту призводить до деградації в цій галузі. У нас купа політиків лікується гомеопатією, що я Вам можу сказати.
Небажання людей вакцинуватися від коронавірусу можна спостерігати не лише в Україні -
про провал кампаній вакцинації можна говорити і в Росії, і в Білорусі.
З 25 жовтня найжорстокіший локдаун запроваджено у Латвії.
Тобто загалом це явище - небажання вакцинуватися - типове для цілої Східної Європи. Чим ви це пояснюєте?
Тим, що відсутня системна політика в галузі пропагування вакцинації.
Насправді дитина має знати, що вакцинація це добре, поки вона дитина. На цьому етапі. Це базові речі, яким я навчаю батьків.
Треба цим системно займатися на рівні держави.
Вчитель, який проти вакцинації, лікар, який проти, політик, який проти - для мене це взагалі незрозуміло, як таке може бути в 21-му сторіччі?
Але тільки треба чітко розуміти, що вакцинація - це не свята корова, до якої не можна підійти.
Треба правильно розставити акценти. Треба почати не боротися з вакцинацією як такою,
а боротися за відповідальну, якісну вакцинацію, добрими препаратами, підготовленими людьми, щоб вони розуміли алгоритми,
коли і якою вакциною, що їм робити в тій чи іншій ситуації, як їм діяти після вакцинації, як реагує організм в тій чи іншій ситуації. Ось це люди мають знати.
Чому так багато недовіри навіть до визнаних у ЄС вакцин, якими щеплювали всі західні країни в країнах Східної Європи?
Відсутність державної політики і здебільшого системи охорони здоров’я.
Найпростіший спосіб повернути довіру - примусити людей рахувати свої гроші.
Я перекладу на зрозумілу мову. Ви щеплені чи ні? У випадку захворювання ви будете оплачувати лікування зі своєї кишені.
Ви будете знати, що у випадку хвороби вас будуть лікувати безкоштовно, якщо ви щеплені.
А якщо не щепленні, то будете оплачувати самі. Все - і жодних проблем!
У вас є страхова  компанія, яка каже: страховий поліс коштує 100 євро на місяць, якщо ви щеплені.
Якщо ні, то страховий поліс коштує 300 євро на місяць.
Це складна схема для України? Ви так не думаєте?
Не бачу нічого складного, якщо взяти за основу інтереси людей. А тут купа інтересів співпадають.
Тільки інше питання, що хтось перестане заробляти, хтось отримає можливість не туди витратити державні кошти.
І ми знову втикаємося в політику, корупцію, мораль. Заробляють на смертях, і це страшно…
Що саме Ви маєте на увазі, як заробляють на смертях?
Я вважаю, що якщо ми проаналізуємо закупки, обладнання, препарати, ціна ремонтів, які були проведені…
Так багато в крані виділяється рельно коштів на закупівлю апаратури, на ремонт, на будівництво. Чому?
Тому що там реально на будь-яку апаратуру і будь-які ремонти завжди закладена дуже серйозна корупційна складова,
що будь-які виділені гроші - з них 20% піде в кишеню чиновникам. Це очевидні речі. Чому на цьому тлі не вкладають в людей?
Коли на медичному приладі вартістю в 100 000 доларів працює лікар з зарплатнею в 6 000 грв - це соромно для країни.
Це один з прикладів, як вбивають систему. А ці втрати лікарів, яких ми втратили як людей! Вони поїхали!
А скільки виїхало медсестер? А скільки ще поїде? У нас криза медсестер! Вона буде більше актуальною, ніж дефіцит лікарів.
Зараз Європа зрозуміє, наскільки це безцінний скарб - наші дівчата-медсестри, які можуть пахати за копійки від ранку до ночі.
Вони їм дадуть не копійки, і всі вони повиїжджають. І що ми будемо робити тоді?
Дехто вважає, що подальшому стрімкому поширенню інфекції могло б перешкодити запровадження по всій країні локдауну.
Чи має це сенс, на Вашу думку?
Сенс локдауну? Нам пояснювали, що коли приходить інфекція, від якої у більшості людей немає імуного захисту,
то може одночасно захворіти величезна купа людей. І це призведе до колапсу системи охорони здоров’я.
Так нам говорили. І ми погоджувалися, бо нам говорили, що тому ми і вводимо локдаун.
Що ви все одно захворієте, але це буде розтягнуто в часі. І на день захворіє не 100 тисяч, а 50 людей, і медичні установи впораються.
Виходить, якщо немає місць у реанімації, то це є колапс! То це не те, що показник для локдауну, а це те, що ви вже спізнилися з його впровадженням!
Але якщо немає місць в стаціонарах, то це не те, що показник для локдауну - це просто палаючий кров'ю показник для локдауну.
А як ви ставитеся до варіанта зробити вакцинацію обов'язковою?
Я вважаю, це не правильно. Хоча б тому, що мають бути базові уявлення про права людини.
Але ми маємо зробити так, щоб не вакцинуватися було соромно, дорого і небезпечно.
Сертифікат про вакцинацію - це перепустка, квиток у нормальне життя.
Не купив квиток - сплачуй набагато більше.
Дитина ходить у державну школу. Це державна школа. Йому держава надає безкоштовну освіту, але за це  вимагає що? Вакцинацію.
Не хочеш щепити дитину, то, раді Бога, іди в приватну школі зі своїми правилами.
Чому медична система країни не підготувалася належним чином?
Адже було зрозуміло, що буде нова хвиля коронавірусу і буде провальна вакцинація…
Вище політичне керівництво країни, Академія медичних наук, МОЗ, купа експертів і організацій - Юнісеф і ВООЗ -
однозначно недооцінили серйозність ситуації, можливість спалаху. Те, що проведено, виявилось недостанім.
Я ще в липні говорив, що треба скликати РНБО обговорювати "дельту". Час втрачений - і це прямий дефект вищого політичного керівництва країни.
І в мене питання: де в усієї цієї парадигмі місце Академії медичних наук?
Де академіки, професори, імунологи тощо? Чому не вони закликають до вакцинації?
Я якщо є недовіра до політиків у людей, то, можливо, є довіра до фахівців?..
Можливо, вони теж не вірять в вакцинацію?
Можливо, академіки не вірять. До речі, вели клількість людей, які називають себе академіками, лікарями, імунологами є прямими антивакцинаторами.
І навіть померлі люди, переповнені морги, кладовища та черги до крематорію їх не переконують.
Що порадите робити людям, які стикаються з корупцією в лікарнях?
Коли, наприклад, пропонують купити кисень або навіть ліжко-місце ?
Треба рятувати своїх близьких. Купуйте!
Ви нічого не можете вимагати від лікаря, якщо не робити його високооплачуваним та поважним!
Якщо є вибір, що кисень на одну людину, ви можете приймаєте рішення в залежності від того, кому важче,
або в залежності від того, хто дасть більше грошей. Можна ж і так, і так?
Найцікавіше те, що прокльони людей, ненависть в результаті будуть направлені на медсестру, яка Васі дала, а Пєті ні.
А люди, які не забезпечили медсестру киснем… Я нещодавно в одному інтерв’ю розповідав, що я відчуваю себе Кассандрою.
І весь час кажу, але ніхто не чує. Ось Кассандра вона була провісницею. Але її ніхто не чув.
Я - класична Кассандра. Все, що, відбувається, я розповідав останні 15 років!
Як лікуватися від коронавірусу, якщо хвороба протікає у легкій або середній формі?
Дві фази. Поки пульсоксиметр показує більше 93-х – у вас легка форма. І це початок, це стандартні дії.
Мінімум їжі, максим води, чисте прохолодне повітря. Ніякого - категорично - режиму ліжка!
Якщо висока температура, то парацетамол та ібупрофен. Все!
Закладений ніс - промийте його сольовим розчином. Крапка.
Але як тільки нижче 93-рьох, то потрібен лікар - кисень, гормони.
Найбільшу помилку, яку ви можете зробити, коли на початку хвороби, коли пульсоксіметр показує норму,  прийняти дексаметазон або антибіотики.
Це те, що вбиває вас максимально. Цього не можна робити. Ваші шанси вижити зменшується до мінімуму.
Амбулаторна допомога при коронавірусі нічим не відрізняється від допомоги при грипі чи нежиті.
Треба починати перейматися тільки тоді, коли відреагував пульсоксиметр. Або у вас є купа інших хвороб.
Ваші поради для профілактики коронавірусу?
Всього два слова - вакцинація і вентиляція.
Вакцинація людей і вентиляція приміщень, максимальний повітрообмін, там, де велика кількість людей.
Які найбільш поширені довгострокові наслідки коронавірусу?
Так званий лонгковід - це проблема із судинами, безсоння, депресія, втомлюваність,
велика кількість усіляких ваших хронічних неврологічних хвороб, гіпертонічна хвороба.
І до речі, один з найголовніших ефектів вакцинації в тому, що вона зменшує вірогідність лонгковіду.
Я не кажу вже про те, що в нас головне завдання в державі - створення і вкладання коштів в систему психіатричної допомоги.
Тому що депресія, панічні атаки, спроби суїциду після короновірусної інфекції - це величезна проблема. І вона буде наростати стрімко.
І ми вже маємо до цього бути готовими. Але я знов Кассандра! Ніхто цього не чує!
Коли, на Вашу думку, можна чекати спад цієї хвилі епідемії?
Цієї хвилі, думаю, стане легше наприкінці січня. А взагалі більш-менш стабільно наприкінці 2022-ого року, хто доживе…
Будуть ще хвилі?
Таких страшних уже ні.
А що видумаєте про походження цього вірусу? Бо існують абсолютно фантастичні теорії…
Я вважаю, вірус має природне походження, але скоріше за все з ним працювали, досліджували і був виток з лабораторії.
Але те, що хтось зробив його своїми рученьками кривими, то я в це не вірю.
Він дуже неперспективний, як зброя масового знищення, тому що він вбиває не сильних, а слабих.
МОЗ України погодив щеплення дітей від "ковіду" віком від 12 до 17-ти років. Погоджена вакцина "Пфайзер/Байонтех". Чи варто щеплювати нею дітей?
Так, однозначно. В першу чергу тому, що діти "вбивають" дорослих.
Вони можуть хворіти в легкій формі. І коли людина хворіє в легкій формі, в неї можуть бути проблеми з рівнем утворення антитіл.
І саме ці люди, які перенесли захворювання в легкій формі, з малим рівнем антитіл , є об'єктами, де відбувається мутація вірусу.
А батькам що б Ви сказали, які бояться, що у дітей з’являться якісь мутації на генному рівні…
Саме тому я бачу тут надвелику проблему. "Я не можу ризикувати здоров’ям своєї дитини, він мені цього не вибачить", -  так скаже мені кожна друга мати.
І будемо мати цю проблему, саме тому що це нав’язує держава і люди будуть протидіяти з усіх сил.
Як загалом вплинула пандемія на дітей? На їхнє психічне здоров'я?
Негативно. Діти не комунікують, часто сидять вдома, спостерігають за бійками батьків.
До речі, велика кількість родин розпалися через коронавірус.
Діти бачать цю нещасну мати, яка не може з дому вийти.
Діти збираються в кімнатах, сидять з чіпсами, дивляться усіляку фігню в інтернеті.
Звичайно, ні про яке психічне здоров’я мова не йде. І це окрема проблема, через яку має зібратися РНБО.
Які наслідки?
Буде наркоманія, токсикоманія, все це буде!
Багато дітей за час карантину підсили на гаджети і особливо на відеоігри.
Вони на них підсили до коронавірусу. Це спосіб життя, комунікації.
Але пандемія посилила це. Що порадите батькам?
Не можна вирішити тільки на рівні батьків. На жаль. Це найбільш гостра проблема цивілізації.
Ми маємо проблему з тим, як діти в цих гаджетах, де є рівні контролю, орієнтуються набагато краще, ніж батьки.
Від них нічого не залежить. Це державна  проблема.
От ви стали батьками, вас треба навчати, що таке безпека в інтернеті, що таке гаджети, які є системи батьківського контролю.
Ви все це мусити знати. Якщо ви батьки 21-го сторіччя!
Не виключено, що в українських школярів попереду новий етап онлайн-навчання. Що порадите вчителям, батькам, державі?
Я можу сказати, що єдиний є варіант відірвати від гаджетів, це коли в реальному житті у дітей щось цікавіше, ніж у цифровому світі.
Коли школа стане центром тяжіння. Не треба пускати дітей в ці класи. Але  пускати дітей на каток, на стадіон! У школі має бути басейн і каток! У кожній!
Так, це не фантазії. Ви вважаєте, що я багато вимагаю? В 21-му столітті технології дозволяють будувати басейни та катки. І це не так дорого.
Якщо це масово і буде будуватися в кожній школі!  І діти будуть знати, що в нього там друзі, активність, спорт. Тоді дитина там буде, а не в гаджетах!
Ви висловилися за скасування уроків фізкультури в школах. Чому? Можете аргументувати?
Тому що урок фізкультури - це дорослі ставлять жирну галочку на своїй совісті, що діти займалися спортом. Це показуха чиста!
Коли діти 45 хвилин дриґають ногами, а потім спітнілі йдуть на фізику… Ні!
Діти мають займатися спортом кожен Божий день! І гроші треба вкладати в це, щоб у кожній школі був спорт.
Чому Ви проти проведення в Україні Олімпійських ігор?
Тому що вкрадуть все, що можливо. Тому що спочатку треба побороти корупцію, а потім проводити Олімпійські ігри.
Від того, що ми провели "Євро-2012" і побудувати чотири стадіони для дорослих хлопців...
Я вважаю, що замість 4-х стадіонів для дорослих хлопців у нас би з’явилося 4000 стадіонів для дітей за ті ж самі гроші,
то це для країни дало б набагато більше і в плані здоров’я, і в плані профілактики наркоманії,
і в плані того, щоб відірвати тисячі дітей від гаджетів. Я однозначно за це!
Ви дуже активні в соцмережах. Як встигаєте і практикувати, і відео для Youtube знімати?
Я практично не займюся практикою зараз. Не приховує це.
Чому?
Мені нудно. Я вже налікувався, надіагностувався, напоховався пацієнтів на 10 лікарських життів наперед.
Ви ж не дорікаєте Шевченку, що він не грає в футбол. Він тренер - і я тренер. Тільки в іншому. Я тренер у комунікаціях.
Я навчаю людей, як бути щасливими. Я навчаю жінок, як стати матір'ю і не перестати бути жінкою. Як примусити чоловіка займатися дітьми.
А приймаю я лише тих пацієнтів, перед якими маю моральний борг. Ми у відповіді за тих, кого приручили.
Чи є амбіції піти у владу?
- Ні.
Можливо, стати міністром охорони здоров'я? І втілити все, що Ви сказали?
Ні, це неможливо реалізувати. Щоб це реалізувати, треба гроші та закони.
Ні законів, ні грошей на сьогодні в нас немає.
І головне - немає доброї волі, щоб усе це в медицині з’явилося. На жаль.
- Дякую.
- На здоров'я!